So far, you added a record button
that is perfectly centered on screen,
on both an iPhone and an iPad.
This is in the view of
the viewController.swift class.
Now we need a way to connect
the record button to the code
in the view controller.
Since we need to work with both the view
and the view controller at the same
time, we need a way to show them
both simultaneously in Xcode.
There's a great way to do this in
Xcode called the assistant editor.
To switch to it, first make sure that
we've selected the main.storyboard file
as you can see here, and
it's showing in the content editor.
Then click the assistant editor
button here on the top right.
It's the one that looks like
two circles, intertwined.
Then, make sure that we have
the view controller selected here.
Things are getting a bit
crowded in our Xcode window.
Let's close out
the inspectors window for
now with the key shortcut, Cmd+Opt+0.
Let's also hide the debug area for now
by pressing the button here to hide it.
We're going to use something called
an ib action to link the button
to the view controller.
It links to pressing of the button to
a function inside the view controller.
This is known as a target action.
The target is the view controller, and
the action is the function
we are about to create.
Select the record button.
You can do it here in
the document outline and
then holding down the Ctrl key, drag
it over until it's right above the last
curly brace inside
the ViewController.swift file.
Let go and then from the drop down,
select Action.
Let's give this action a name,
such as recordAudio.
And then click the Connect button.
You can see Xcode has created
a function for us called recordAudio,
and has connected this button to this
function in the viewController class.
We can see this function is connected
because it has this filled in circle
here on the left side of the bar.
This filled in circle indicates that
this is a special type of function,
called an IB action, that has a button
or other UI element connected to it.
Now every time the user
presses the record button,
this function is going to get called.
A good practice in software development
is to test your code often.
Our pitch perfect app is no exception.
Let's add a line of what I like to call
caveman debugging to this function,
to print out to the console
that the button was pressed.
Inside this function let's
add a print command.
So that we can just print out,
record button was pressed,
every time the user presses this button.
Let's press the run button and
test this app out.
In my case I've selected the iPhone
6S as the simulator to use.
Now when I press the record button,
I can see the record button
pressed is showing in the console.
Press it again,
I can see that it's happening there.
It's listing here on the right.
Why do i call it caveman debugging?
Well, it's the oldest and
simplest form of debugging your code,
just by logging
something to the console.
Later in these courses, you're going to
learn some really powerful ways to
watch, debug, and
step into the execution of your code.
For now, we can be content
with using caveman debugging
to ensure that the record audio
function is getting called.